VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: I'm Vinod.
I'm a product manager at Google.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: And
I'm Guillaume LaForge.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And I'm also a Java champion.
And I'd be curious to know
who's a Java developer
in the audience?
Yay!
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Yeah, that's awesome.
You are in the
right place today.
A quick housekeeping note--
I know all of you are using the
app here for the conference.
So we have a Dory for
questions and answers.
So feel free to put in your
questions as the talk goes on.
And we'll address
them at the end.
So let's get started.
So here's a quick
agenda for the talk.
So we're going to give you a
brief overview of serverless
at Google Cloud, and
then specifically get
into the What's New in
Java and serverless.
And after that, provide a
demo-- we have an exciting demo
over a broad range of products.
And then, conclude
with serverless
beyond compute for some
additional offerings
beyond our compute spectrum.
So to start off with, what is
serverless in Google Cloud?
So our definition of
serverless in Google Cloud
is to build and run software
without provisioning,
managing, or maintaining
physical or virtual machines,
completely easing the
pain of the users.
Just give us your code,
and we'll run it for you.
Furthermore, to
elaborate on that,
we consider that to be an
operating model, zero server
management.
We consider it to be
completely secure.
And pay for only what you use,
in terms of a billing model.
Additionally, we want
developer experience
and a programming
model focused around
service-based management.
So you build your
own microservices
that you deploy in the Cloud.
We want it to be event-driven.
So you submit a image
to a GCS bucket,
and you trigger
a Cloud Function,
or any other event--
submit a Pub/Sub message--
or any other activity that
you have to trigger sprinkles
of computer code in the Cloud.
Lastly, we want it to be open
with zero vendor lock-in.
And these are the two
paradigms around which
we define serverless,
an operating
model and a programming model.
And we have what we call
a full stack serverless
offering in Google Cloud,
spread across seven areas.
A bunch of compute offerings--
but over broad other areas
such as storage, DevOps, data
analytics, messaging, ML & AI,
smart and chatbots.
A lot of these technologies
are decade long
of Google engineering
experience exposed to you.
For example, BigQuery
is like a big engine
that we are working
on for several years.
And we exposed that as a
serverless offering for you.
In this talk, we're
going to jump deeper
into some of the compute
offerings, especially, and also
the Java offerings
in this space.
So to start off
with-- you know, we
want to talk about
Cloud Functions which
is, in compute, a source-based
event driven functions.
A simple example
would be like you
submit an image to
Google Cloud Storage
and you want some
work done on it.
So you can trigger a bunch
of APIs to do that work.
After Cloud Functions,
the next thing
in the spectrum we talk
about is App Engine.
App Engine is our decades-long
old serverless offering.
If you want to
build a simple web
app in your favorite
programming language,
with stateless,
serverless offerings,
we consider App Engine
as something for that.
And then we have
our latest offering,
which is Cloud Run, which
is serverless containers
for fully managed
HTTP request response,
which can be run on a fully
managed system within Google
Cloud, as well as on
Kunernetes engine.
So dig deeper into Cloud
Functions specifically.
As I mentioned
before, we consider
Cloud Functions as our
event-driven serverless
compute platform.
What we envision it as
triggering sprinkles
of computer code,
which basically then
help you build your applications
of gluing together code
around your radius services.
For example, you have
different Cloud services
that could even invoke
Cloud Functions that
invoke different APIs,
the result of which
is then processed
by these services.
As I said, upload an
image to Cloud Storage,
do some work using an ML
API, the result of which
could then be stored in
Google Cloud Storage as well.
It's a fully managed offering.
It scales automatically.
And it's pay per use.
We consider it to be a
streamlined development model,
where you write your
function and deploy it
with a single command.
And it has integration for
events with different GCP
products, as well as HTTP.
Classic use cases
for Cloud Functions
could be like webhooks.
You know, you have different
clients that invoke a webhook,
and then that could
start triggering a HTTP
function to process some work.
You can invoke different
APIs to a Cloud Function,
such as the ML API and so on.
And events-- events
are very imperative.
For example, a good
use case for this
could be like if
you had BigQuery
and you had a lot of audit
logs that you wanted to track,
and you went through
logging accurately,
such as with Stackdriver,
which files events,
you could then use functions
to process those events
and do some analytics on that.
The next use case would
be Lightweight ETL.
For example, you upload
certain data to Cloud Storage,
and then you can
trigger a Cloud Function
to do some processing
on that data,
and then store the
analysis in a data store.
And lastly, iOT
and edge devices--
if you have different
edge devices deployed
across all the world
regions, like if you're
an oil company or
any other company,
those events could be
fired into the Cloud
maybe through a
messaging system,
and then you invoke a
function to do some processing
to store the results.
So these broad
range of use cases
can be accommodated
under Cloud Functions,
or function as a
service, as we call it.
Currently, Cloud Functions is
offered in these run times.
They're all GA.
In these same run times, we
have additional versions,
which are beta and alpha.
And today, we are really
excited to announce
Java on Cloud Functions.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Woohoo!
Thank you.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Thank you.
The team's been working
really hard for it.
Many of the engineers
are sitting right here.
So you know, like we have
been really excited to get
this ready for you.
And to go deep dive into
Cloud Functions in general
as a product, we
would also recommend
you attend the Run Cloud
Functions Everywhere talk.
It's by my colleague
Stewart Reichling.
It's a very exciting talk,
and I highly recommend it.
Going on from Cloud
Functions to App Engine--
so as I mentioned
before, App Engine
is our 10-year-old
serverless offering.
It was one of the earliest
serverless offerings.
If you want to build
your traditional web
app on your favorite language
such as Node.js, Python,
or Java, you can
use App Engine along
with frameworks such as
Express, Flask, and Spring.
The product [INAUDIBLE] use
advanced management features
such as application
versioning, traffic splitting,
IP firewalls, logging,
monitoring, and so on.
We've [INAUDIBLE],, which are all
GA, such as PHP, GO, Node.js.
Further, we're really excited to
have Java 11 on App Engine, as
well as Ruby.
Further on moving
down, I want to talk
about the most recent
offering, which
is Cloud Run, which
is serverless agility
for containerized apps.
We've talked about it
a lot in Next recently,
and I want to elaborate a
little bit more about it.
What this basically means
is taking a container
from production to
deployment in seconds.
Just give us a container in
any language or any library,
and with a single command,
it gets immediately deployed
in Google Cloud and you
have a URL in seconds.
Further, we consider this to be
a natively serverless offering.
What this basically means is you
don't-- as I mentioned before,
you don't have to
manage any servers.
Just focus on writing your code.
It scales up very quickly.
It scales down to zero.
And you pay exactly
for what you use,
the lifecycle of a request.
And it's one experience
where you want to want it.
What this basically means is
you have a unified developer
experience on where you want
to run your application.
For example, if
you want to run it
on a fully managed deployment
within Google Cloud, you could.
If you want to run
it on GKE, Cloud Run
works on Cloud
Run and GKE, where
you get additional
control on your cluster.
And if you don't run it
on Google Cloud at all,
this entire technology is based
on what is called Knative.
And you can run Knative on your
on-prem systems on Kubernetes
and run your containers there.
By doing this, we
want to make sure
that you have the full spectrum
of offerings across the Cloud
and on-prem systems with
zero vendor lock-in.
So now, what's the Java
story for serverless?
So we're excited to
announce, as I mentioned,
Java 8 on Google
Cloud Functions.
Furthermore, we have Java
11 on App Engine standard.
It's a great offering.
And I highly recommend
you to try it.
And then we have Java
on Cloud Run, where
you can run your favorite
framework, such as Spring
and so on, on our
Cloud Run offering.
Given this, we'd now
like to try a demo.
We have an exciting
demo from Guillaume.
And he'll take it from there.
Could you switch to
the demo, please?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
So Cloud Functions,
App Engine, Cloud
Run-- we'll demonstrate
the three products.
So here is the typical screen
from the Cloud Console.
And we have a
couple of functions,
which are already deployed.
So when you create a
function, what happens?
So let's say I have--
next.
What's new for you
today, Java developers?
It's the fact that we now
have this line, Java 8,
Alpha, that you can see here.
And it allows me to
write my Java code here.
So I have a Java file here.
And I also have a POM.xml
file, because when
you do a source deployment
of your Java functions,
we're using Maven to
build your Java code.
But you can also do a fat
Jar deployment as well.
So here, if you have
already pre-compiled
and you're using, for
example, a different
build tool, such as
Gradle you can do that
without needing Maven.
But here, when you
do source deployment,
we build transparently
for you in Cloud Build.
And we're using Maven for that.
So let's have a look at--
well, we can actually
start with the POM.xml,
this Maven build file.
So notice that I'm specifying
Java 8 for compilation purpose,
because I'm using Java 8.
And I added this
servlet dependency
because we're using the
servlet dependency here.
And perhaps I can put it there.
It might be a bit bigger
and should be more readable.
So this is a simple class.
And we have our
processing function, here,
which is called helloWorld.
It takes a request parameter,
HttpServletRequest, as well as
a HttpServletResonse.
Then from the response,
I'm getting the writer.
And I'm going to
write on the output
my little hello, world message.
So I've already
deployed it earlier.
And I can easily
test it from there.
Testing-- and then it's
going to call my function
and print hello, world.
Yes, hello, world.
But since it's about Java-- but
it's not just Java in the sense
that on the Java
ecosystem, there
are also alternative languages.
So I wanted to show you
the fact that we can also
run with other
Java-friendly languages.
So I have another example.
I can show you
that, for example,
in my Visual Studio Code.
I am using Groovy.
I'm the Apache
Groovy co-founder.
So that's why I'm biased.
And I like this
language on the JVM.
So it's pretty simple.
It's just a Groovy
script similarly
to what we had with Java 8.
We just have the process
method here-- no need for class
or anything surrounding this.
And same thing-- I'm
getting the writer.
And I'm writing on the output.
And I just wanted
to show you as well,
since we did the deployment
earlier with the console,
the web console.
You can also deploy
it from there
with G Cloud on the command line
with G Cloud Functions Deploy,
the name of my function.
I specify that I want to
use the Java 8 runtime,
even if it's another language.
That's OK.
HTTP trigger-- and
the entry-point,
that's actually main.
That's the name of my
Groovy script and process,
the name of the method.
And I'm doing I'm doing
a deployment from source.
So I'm saying that's
the source, dot.
I can also do that for a Jar.
So if I have a fat Jar
already pre-compiled,
I can also deploy it from there.
And then just to prove that
it works, I can show you.
Testing-- and it should
print hello, Groovy world,
in a few milliseconds.
Yes, hello, Groovy world.
So we saw HTTP functions.
But we also support
background functions
such as new file uploaded
to Cloud Storage,
and you want to be
notified and have
your functions being invoked
when a new file is stored.
Pub/Sub-- when you
receive messages
on a topic from
Pub/Sub, et cetera.
And actually, I didn't mention
that as I was using the default
HTTP Select box here.
But you can also specify, OK, I
want to create a Pub/Sub method
and you can see-- oh,
this is still Node, sorry.
And you have some of the samples
here to help you get started.
And to illustrate those
background functions,
I would like to highlight
this demonstration here.
If you go to the showcase
on the exhibition floor,
there's a Cloud
Functions demo which
is running that's
Serverless Postcard.
And it's a little
application which allows
you to select a picture--
for example, this one.
You can customize and give
a little message there,
hello, attendees.
And it's going to
process my picture
with all the runtimes
that we have,
so Node, Python, Go, and Java.
And notice that Java
is pretty fast, right?
As fast as-- it's
actually the fastest, yes.
So I'm not going
to say anything.
I don't want to--
if they are non-Java
developers, the other runtimes
are totally great.
But-- [LAUGHS] my function
was super fast in Java,
and it was fast in Go as well.
So you can click on
the View Code button
to see what the code looks like.
And there's a little
sharing button
which puts a message on Twitter
and shares this picture.
And I wanted to show you
this architecture diagram.
So what do we have?
That's an Angular application,
which is also using
Firebase with an AJAX call.
It's going to call a
first Java function,
this HTTP function here.
We pass the name of the
file, the picture file name,
as well as the message.
This function is going to post
a little request on Pub/Sub
on a particular topic.
And then this message, because
those four functions here
in Go, Python,
Node, and Java are
going to be woken up because
there's a new message coming up
on a topic.
So those functions here
are Pub/Sub functions,
triggered functions.
Then those functions
will process the picture,
add the frame, type
the message, et cetera.
And once they are
done, they are going
to save the resulting
picture in cloud storage.
Since we stored something
on cloud storage,
there's going to be another
asynchronous event notifying
another Java function, which
will retrieve all the pictures
and update some metadata in
my Cloud Firestore database.
And also because I'm using
Firebase on the front end,
I'm able to update
the front end as soon
as I gather all the URLs
of the pictures that
have been processed.
So what I'd like to show you
is one of the Java functions--
the one doing the
image processing,
which is a Pub/Sub function, and
the one doing the cloud storage
event handling.
So let's have a look
at the code here.
So this is my image processor.
I'm going to hide that
to have a bit more space.
So this function is going to
receive a Pub/Sub message.
So that's my process
method, the Pub/Sub message.
Actually, under the hood,
we're using the GSON library,
which does marshaling,
unmarshaling of JSON
to and from Java objects.
And if you go at
the very bottom,
actually there's my Pub/Sub
class here that's unmarshaled.
And I'm interested
in the data field
because this data field contains
my image request payload
with the file name,
message, et cetera.
So I'm receiving that.
I also have access to--
it's an optional parameter.
There's a context if I need some
additional data about the event
ID, timestamp, event
type, resource, et cetera.
I'm not using it
in the function,
but I will need to show
this context class.
Then I'm just decoding the
data from the Pub/Sub message,
and there, I'm using
JSON directly because I
know that what's in the
payload of the Pub/Sub message
is actually some JSON content.
So I want to get an
instance of my image request
which contains the
file name, et cetera.
I'm doing a bit of
cloud storage handling
because I want to retrieve--
where is it?
Yeah, image download--
I want to retrieve
the image from cloud storage.
That's where I store
all my pictures.
And then there's a
long part of the code--
you're not allowed to
look at it too closely--
where I'm actually using Java
2D to do the image generation.
And when I go towards the end,
once I've drawn my picture,
I'm going to write that
and store that again
in another bucket
in cloud storage.
So that's what I'm
doing there, actually.
OK, so this new processed
image is in cloud storage,
so it's going to invoke,
asynchronously, another
function which I call
the watchdog, which
is going to update Firestore
with this new information.
So similarly, I have
a GCS event that's
actually myself who
created and defined
this class at the bottom.
I just used the bucket
and the name fields,
but there are other
additional attributes,
but I'm just interested
in those two.
So I just create a simple
class with those two fields.
And then, here, I'm going to
use Firestore to specify--
so I'm doing some
regex stuff to retrieve
the name of the runtime
and things like that.
And once I have
that metadata, I'm
going to put the information
in the Firestore.
So I've got my
document reference,
and then I'm going to, here,
set the data in Firestore.
And then that's what is going,
later on, to update the UI here
with--
so if I do another little
test with some random message,
once the data is
stored in Firestore,
it's updating the
pictures down below.
So that's about it for
functions in Java--
HTTP functions, background
functions with cloud storage,
and Pub/Sub.
All right, so let's now
have a look at App Engine.
So I have a prepared
another little
demo where you upload a picture
and it's going to be-- well,
it's somehow artistic in a way.
So I'm redrawing the picture
with some squares, circles,
and letters.
So here, I'm going
to take a picture
that I have locally here.
So I'm going to take a picture
of one of our colleagues,
Roberto, who was one of the
architects behind Java EE
and also one of
the key engineers
working on App Engine Java.
So it's a bit unfortunate that
he's not there with us anymore
because he passed
away recently, but I
wanted to show that we
had him in our thoughts.
And I'm going to use--
for the letters, I'm going
to use his first name.
I'm submitting that
and it's going to draw.
So I'm uploading the
picture, and then it
takes a second or two
to draw the picture.
And here is an artistic vision
of this original picture.
So I'd like to show you
how I implemented that
with App Engine Java 11.
So I'm going to switch to here.
So what do you see here?
First thing I'd
like to highlight
is that you're not limited to
servlet-based web frameworks.
You can use any web
framework that you
want to create your App Engine
applications on the Java 11
runtime.
So that's why I decided
to use Micronaut.
It's a super fast, with
super slow startup,
framework, which is pretty
straightforward and pretty easy
to use.
So I have a controller
here for which I actually
inject my service
class that's going
to do the image manipulation.
So here, I'm serving the
static assets with the form.
And here, more
interestingly, that's
the URL when the form
that you saw earlier
is going to post the picture
and the message and the letters
that I've chosen
to this process end
point through a multipart form.
And either I'm going to return
OK, if everything goes fine,
or server error.
And here, this is the
part where I'm actually
calling my service, Artist
Service, which is here.
And so it's a singleton service
that I injected earlier.
And then I'm doing,
again, some Java 2D.
You're going to think
I'm a fan of Java 2D.
So I get the bytes
of the picture
and I'm going to return the
bytes of the processed image.
And then, well, some Java
2D stuff, Java 2D, Java 2D.
And then I'm putting
the bytes back,
and that's what this
service returns.
So that's basically how it was
implemented, but let me have
a look at the app YAML file.
So I mentioned that
we don't have to use
servlet-based frameworks.
Here, I'm using actually just
a fat JAR that I compiled here.
So I'm using Gretel
for the build,
but it's irrelevant here.
I created a fat JAR of my
application that I can deploy.
And notice that I actually
have full control of the entry
point, meaning that I can pass
things like garbage collection
parameters.
I can pass any kind of
parameter to customize
the way I'm going to launch
and invoke the Java command.
So fat JARs, not limited
to servlet-based payloads
and workloads, and
full control on how
the Java command is invoked.
So really, no limits anymore,
thanks to this new Java 11
runtime.
And my last demo,
that's this one.
So this time, I decided
to use cloud run.
It's a little Sudoku
puzzle generator,
so you can generate as
many puzzles as you want.
So I'm using the Google Cloud
the hexagons, the logos.
I can define different levels.
I want a hard puzzle, I want
an easy puzzle, et cetera.
The thing is, I had--
there was a tool that I
was interested in using
called QQWing.
That's the name of
the project, which is
a Sudoku generator and solver.
But it's a binary application.
So I don't necessarily have--
I wanted somehow to be
able to use that binary C,
C++ application within the
context of my Java application,
first thing.
Second thing, I
wanted to experiment
with new features of Java.
The Java language--
for example, Java 12--
has added a new experimental
feature actually,
which is the new
switch expression which
are more streamlined compared
to the old switch case.
So let me show you what I did.
So just because I
can, I thought that I
could use yet another
framework and I'm using--
I should start from
the bottom there.
Here.
So there's lots of red
in Visual Studio Code.
That's because I'm using
those new Java syntax
constructs that are
not supported yet
in Visual Studio Code.
So that's why there's
lots of red underline.
So here, I'm using the
Rat Pack framework,
which is also a very
lightweight framework, not based
on servlets, which is
using the NETI library.
So I define my server.
I say, I'm listening
on port 8080.
I'm serving some static
content, for example,
of all the pictures
of the hexagons.
And then I've got two routes.
So I have one for displaying
the pictures, the hexagons.
And the other one
which is the one which
generates the sudokus.
And I'm passing
a path parameter,
which is the level here.
And what I wanted
to do is to use
this Java 12 experimental
switch expression notation.
So notice that it's a
little bit different
compared to the old
switch case statement.
So you can specify
different values,
like easy and cool
on the same line,
and you're using an arrow
instead of the columns.
And you don't have
to use the break.
So for that, I really
needed to use Java 12.
Of course, I could have
used an if/else statement,
but just because
I can, I did it.
So I have this switch
statement, and I also
wanted to show here that I
am using the process builder
to invoke my sudoku generator.
So that's what I'm doing here.
I'm starting the process,
and I'm going to retrieve
the output of this
C, C++ program.
And let me show you what my
build and my Docker container
look like.
So as you can see in my build--
I'm using Gretel for the build.
As you can see, I specify
that I want to use the Java 12
syntax level.
But when I'm
compiling my code, I'm
also using this special
Java compiler flag
Enable Preview, which enables
this new experimental syntax.
What else?
That's about it.
Here, I'm also using the shadow
plugging, which is doing--
which creates fat JARs when
you use Gretel for the build.
And the docker file.
Let's have a look
at the docker file.
So it's a multi-stage
docker build.
I actually have the
first step, which
is about building my application
and invoking the shadow JAR
command to create my fat JAR.
So this is this part
building my app.
But then, here's the
image I'm going to use
and that I'm going to
push on the cloud run.
So I needed-- oops, sorry.
I needed my little
binary file here
for generating the sudokus.
And from the first
stage of my build,
I'm retrieving the fat JAR.
And then what else?
I'm exposing port 8080.
And then I can specify
the entry point as well,
and specify, OK,
I'm launching a JAR
and I'm enabling this
preview feature that
should be available when
I'm running my code.
So if you look at
the very bottom,
you can see how I build with
Docker and then Docker Run.
So I can run that locally
without a problem.
And then I must have somewhere
a docker push command.
Well, somewhere in my history.
It's too far.
So I can very easily,
again, push my own--
whichever version of Java that
I want to use in my application.
Here I'm using Java 12.
And I can use, of course--
anything that can be put
in a Docker container,
basically, I can put that there.
And then I have my
service running here,
my sudoku-generator service
running in the cloud run cloud
console.
Yes, that's about
it for the demos.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Yeah, thank you
for the exciting
demo, Guillaume.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
So as you all saw,
we saw our Java offerings across
Cloud Functions, App Engine,
and Cloud Run with
the live demo.
So super exciting demo,
thank you very much.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: So
switching back to the slides
as we move on with
our talk, we want
to talk about Serverless
Beyond Compute.
And specifically, the thing that
we wanted to talk about here
was compute is
not just a vacuum.
You need ancillary products to
work with serverless offerings
to build an end-to-end service.
For example, let's say you
want to run a Cloud Function,
but you want to run
it on a schedule,
like every Friday morning
or so on, to do some work.
Or you want to queue a bunch of
tasks or a bunch of functions
to be executed at a
later point in time--
a month later, a
week later, or so on,
or you want some
retry semantics.
Then you need some kind of
queue to queue those works
to various microservices.
Or if you want to store your
end results in a data store,
you need a data store where you
can store the result for, say,
your ML work being processed
from a Cloud Function.
So given that, I'm
going to talk to you
about two specific products
that could help in building
these end-to-end applications.
The first is Cloud Tasks.
Cloud Tasks is a
point-to-point queuing system
for asynchronous tasks
across microservices.
It's a queuing product for
reliable task offloading.
It's a fully managed service.
If you have any
long-running async work,
such as you have
a job that needs
to be run to process
an image and the end
result of the processing
needs to be stored somewhere,
you can queue it up in
this particular product.
It has really good rate
limits and retry controls.
In queuing systems,
it's very important,
if you have a
workflow of systems,
that you set the limit to the
weakest link in the chain.
Cloud Tasks really
gives the end users
a control to set these rate
limits and retry semantics.
So based on the guarantee
needs of your system,
you can tweak it accordingly.
Further, it provides
for flexible routing
with HTTP Auth.
So you can hit your end
points and services securely
within Google Cloud, as well
as your on-prem systems.
To know more about Cloud
Tasks and its retry semantics,
its rate limits, dynamic
scheduling, and other features,
we have a dedicated
session for this
called Cloud Tasks,
Point-to-Point Asynchronous
Tasks Across
Microservices tomorrow.
We really appreciate it
if you can come there.
It's an exciting
product and the team's
worked really hard for it.
Moving on, as you're
building the systems,
we always need a Cron system.
For example, if you're
scheduling functions
every Friday, you need
something that you
can set your schedules on.
And at Google Cloud, we have a
product called Cloud Scheduler.
It's what we call
Cron for the Cloud.
It's a reliable
enterprise-grade Cron scheduler
that can reach
different endpoints,
such as HTTP, Pub/Sub,
and App Engine targets.
It's fully managed and
pay for what you use.
It supports the popular
Unix Cron syntax
and has a delightful
UI experience,
so you can create your
schedules from the UI, as well
as the CLI.
Furthermore, you have a really
good monitoring dashboard,
so you can track the status
of your jobs through the UI
and also take corrective
action wherever necessary.
This is something
that is very common.
We have seen a lot
of customers use
Cloud Functions coupled with
Cloud Scheduler on a recurring
schedule.
They really like the
Unix Cron syntax,
so we highly recommend trying
this product out as well.
Additionally, it
offers security so you
can hit the different
endpoints with security
and authentication both
within Google Cloud, as well
as your on-prem systems.
To know more about
Cloud Scheduler,
we have a session,
Serverless in the Real
World, Customer Stories
from Smart Cities
to Retail Analytics.
It's by Bret McGowen, one
of our developer advocates.
And we have a 15-minute
dedicated session
from one of our customers
who is using the product.
So we highly recommend that you
attend this session as well.
So that's pretty much
the summary of our talk.
And in terms of next
steps, we highly
encourage you to try our Java
offerings on Google Cloud.
We also recommend you to sign
up for the Cloud Functions
on Java 8.
Here's a QR code.
If you have any questions,
feel free to reach out
to us anytime.
Both our contacts are here.
We have another Java talk by one
of our developer advocates, Ray
Tsang.
We talked about a lot
of serverless offerings
here for Java, but if you
want to run Java applications
on Kubernetes and do
a deep dive on that,
he has a really
good session on that
and it's really
exciting as well.
To summarize,
we've spoken to you
about various Java offerings
across Cloud Functions, App
Engine, as well as Cloud Run.
These are really
interesting products
and giving you the
option to pick and choose
what you want
based on your needs
is something that
we wanted to do.
And we've demoed that, as
well, with Guillaume here.
So yeah, at this point, we are--
thank you very much
for attending the talk.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]